bonsoir et les crevettes merci d'être
avec nous avons décidément un mauvaise
séquence qui se poursuit pour valérie
pécresse critiqué sur la forme mais
aussi sur le fond parfois oui alors je
regardais il ya une belle citation de
victor hugo quand on sort un peu dans
tous les sens mais là qui colle pile
poil j'ose dire c'est la phrase suivante
la forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface donc en fait on peut pas
dissocier la forme du fonds et c'est
vrai que valérie pécresse dimanche à son
meeting parisien du zénith a marqué les
esprits mais sans doute pas dans le bon
sens on l'attendait meilleur oratrice on
l'attendait avec des éléments
programmatiques un peu plus fort on a eu
le sentiment par moments et une partie
de l'auditoire ou des gens qui
regardaient ce meeting en été un peu mal
à l'aise parce qu'on avait l'impression
qu'elle qu'elle enchaînait des phrases
de communicants au collées les unes
derrière les autres ce qui lui a pas
rendu service peut-être qu'il aurait été
préférable je n'ai pas de conseils mais
il aurait été préférable qu'elles
ciblent davantage par exemple emmanuel
macron qui va rentrer en campagne et
qu'elle essaie d'installer un espèce de
face à face entre lui entre elle et le
chef de l'état qui lorsqu'ils seraient
entrés en campagne aurait été de obligé
de répondre à la lecture par exemple du
bilan qu'elle aurait fait de son
quinquennat elle n'a pas fait du tout ça
est là je pense pas su incarner
suffisamment le son contenu maintenant
il ya des choses intéressantes mais sur
le fond justement là j'ai parlé de la
forme on va parler du fond bon je vais
pas parler du grand déclassement ou du
grand placement puisqu'elle s'est
expliquée dessus mais elle parle d'une
nouvelle france 1 c'est un peu ce le
concept de valérie pécresse et ça m'a
fait furieusement penser à quelque chose
qui remontent pour les plus anciens qui
s'appelait la nouvelle société de
jacques chaban delmas alors c'est assez
marrant parce que si la nouvelle france
répond d'une certaine manière à la
nouvelle société de jacques chaban
delmas ça manque pas de sel quand même
d'avoir une chiraquienne pur jus puisque
valérie pécresse sur les clubs de chirac
et pas de nicolas sarkozy ça manque pas
de sel de voir quelques elle s'engouffre
dans ce concept alors que chaban delmas
évidemment a toujours
c'est toujours opposé à comme héritier
du gaullisme jacques chirac veille
pécresse on l'a vu elles sont expliquées
certes mais enfin le court un petit peu
après sa droite évidemment
marine le pen eric zemmour qui sont dans
les sondages est en tout cas eric
zemmour jubile et capitalisant sur les
déboires de valérie pécresse oui alors
il faudra voir les premiers sondages qui
ne vont pas tarder peut-être à tomber
demain ou après demain après ce fameux
meeting du zénith à paris pour valérie
pécresse mais moi j'ai eu le sentiment
en écoutant vers les pécresse elle a eu
des phrases extrêmement forte par
exemple une marianne ne peut pas être
voilées ce sont des thématiques
évidemment que qu'eric zemmour met sur
la table régulièrement moi j'ai eu
l'impression qu'elle essayer d'installer
une sorte de nouvelle primaire il ya eu
la primaire les républicains qui ont
départagé qui ont permis avec pécresse
d'émerger j'ai l'impression à tort
qu'elle installer une nouvelle primaire
avec eric zemmour avec les thématiques
d'eric zemmour alors je ne suis pas
certain que pour son électorat notamment
le plus centriste ce soit bénéfique et
qu'elle en tire davantage de pourcentage
dans les sondages mais ça illustre quoi
en réalité ça illustre la difficulté
qu'a valérie pécresse depuis qu'elle a
été désignée comme candidate des
républicains a à la fois jouer avec son
aile droite celle qu'incarne eric ciotti
le député des alpes-maritimes et à
donner des gages également à des gens
qui sont plus santé c'est oublier pas
elle a eu l'appui de l'ue dit le parti
de jean christophe lagarde qui est un
parti officiellement centriste donc en
fait cette espèce de grand écart
permanent l'obligera à être extrêmement
souple est ce que ça lui permettra de de
ramasser très large rien n'est moins sûr
maintenant est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux
comme elle le dit d'être une grande
oratrice pour gagner l'élection
présidentielle
vous vous souvenez sans doute de ce
meeting d'emmanuel macron où ils
s'égosillait la voix éraillée à dire
c'est notre projet alors c'est vrai
qu'il avait un magnétisme avec la salle
emmanuel macron qu'elle n'a sans doute
pas eu au zénith valérie pécresse mais
en tout cas on peut se poser la question
maintenant sur le programme il ya des
choses intéressantes me semble-t-il pour
valérie pécresse mais l'un des juges de
paix ce sera évidemment le ou les
premiers sondages qui vont tomber hélas
si elle décroche alors attention parce
que marine le pen et eric zemmour qui
sont en embuscade pourrait en profiter
et puis qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
les jours qui viennent vous le verrez
sans doute une partie des élus peut-être
les républicains vont rejoindre emmanuel
macron parce que les plus centristes
considérons qu'elle a un discours trop
fort et au contraire peut-être que les
plus à droite chez les républicains
parmi les élus rejoindront au contraire
le camp d'eric zemmour une marine le pen
donc elle est sur la corde raide c'est
un moment compliqué mais qu'elle a
assumé ce matin sur une radio en disant
moi j'ai une pudeur et à cause ou grâce
à cette pudeur je ne m'exprime pas comme
vous avez l'habitude qu'on s'exprime
comme d un confrère d'une autre chaîne
la plus proche de mer quelques de johnny
hallyday peut-être valérie pécresse des
mourants eric zemmour décidément la
cible de toutes les critiques avec
parfois même des dérapages à gauche
celui de yannick jadot oui c'est
clairement un dérapage yannick jadot
crédit sur une sur une radio ce week-end
qu'eric zemmour était le juif de service
qui servait l'antisémitisme moi je pense
que c'est une déclaration antisémite le
juif de service ça renvoie dans le
lexique français à des moments quand
même extrêmement sombres de notre
histoire et j'ajoute parce qu'il faut
essayer d'être objectif que si une
personnalité femme ou homme de droite
avait employé ce titre de ce type de
slogans à l'encontre d'eric zemmour ou
de quelqu'un d'autre je pense que la
levée de bouclier médiatique aurait été
beaucoup plus importante alors je ne dis
pas comme disent les jeunes que c'est
pas ces crèmes parce que yannick jadot à
mon avis a regretté ce qu'il avait dit
mais en tout cas ça n'a pas soulevé
l'exaspération à laquelle on pouvait
s'attendre
devant de telles déclarations et en
attendant le boulevard toujours pour
emmanuel macron alors boulevard pour
emmanuel macron
il ya quand même des petit caillou dans
sa chaussure un vous parler depuis tout
à l'heure de la crise ukrainienne le
président
mais le président de la république est
revenu de son tête à tête de 5h30 avec
l'annuaire poutine en étant persuadé
qu'il avait obtenu la désescalade si par
un revers de l'histoire les choses
dégénérer en ukraine eh bien je pense qu
emmanuel macron ne serait pas
extrêmement comptable est content du
bilan qui devrait défendre sur cette
parenthèse diplomatique
donc c'est bien de jouer les matamores
et les chefs d'état qui incarne et qui
veulent en imposer aux autres mais si ça
tourne court alors ce qui pouvait être
un avantage pour lui va s'avérer
peut-être dans les jours qui viennent
une grande complication politique et
puis je reparle de valérie pécresse pour
terminer stéphanie
il faut voir aussi qu'il ya toute une
stratégie politique est en train de se
mettre en place que j'entends beaucoup
alors c'est du bas bruit pour l'instant
mais j'entends beaucoup de gens de
gauche qui estime que pour reconstruire
la gauche la meilleure des solutions ce
serait que valérie pécresse soit élu
qu'elle incarne le camp de droite
républicaine et cette petite musique là
n'est pas inintéressante parce qu'on a
une partie de l'électorat de gauche qui
est testé et qui dit oui pourquoi pas
voter valérie pécresse dont vous voyez
il peut y avoir beaucoup d'ingrédients
dans cette campagne
tant que le chef de l'état sortant
n'aimiez pas rentrer et on va on
attendra que les morceaux du puzzle se
mettent en place réellement mais vous
savez parfois les stratégies politiques
sont très compliquée à décrypter et
aboutissent le jour venu le jour j à des
surprises qu'on n'avait pas vu
effectivement dans la déjà et merci
beaucoup eric revel d'avoir été avec
nous merci pour votre décryptage